this is about the american people's
right to vote it is about their access
to the right to vote in a meaningful way
are you serious the election procedures
of the united states would be
federalized
ballot harvesting legalized and public
funding of elections
made law you're a damned liar meanwhile
it's also politically palatable to say
that everything is racist because when
you call things racist it means you get
to condemn your political opponents
which brings us of course
to the death of senate bill 1 this was
the for the people
act the senate senate bill 1 died an
ignominious death yesterday
when republicans did not vote for the
advancement of the bill in a procedural
vote they didn't
kill the filibuster just to move along
with this thing there's a 50 50 split by
the way
there's a 50 50 split in the senate um
and you require 60 votes in order to
advance the bill
according to axios senate republicans
filibuster democrats signature voting
rights bill
on tuesday denying it the 60 votes
needed to advance the bill and start
debate
first of all let me just point this out
with the media the media always call
this a quote-unquote voting rights bill
it is not a voting rights bill it is a
federalized
voting procedures bill i mean they they
just use propaganda terms straight from
the democratic playbook
and democrats will say well this is a
voting rights bill and immediately the
media will start parroting that this is
a voting rights bill
and if there is a if there is a bill
that suggests that
boys be allowed to compete with girls
and girls spores they will call it a
transgender rights bill
they won't call it a reclassification of
sex in sport bill which is far
more informational they always just take
whatever is the democratic euphemism for
the thing and then they just call it the
thing so if you were just a normal
reader who doesn't follow this stuff
very closely be like oh my god
the democrats were pushing a voting
rights bill and republicans oppose that
they must hate voting rights
this is this is why the media are just
garbage at their jobs
according to axios it's unexpected but
significant blow to democrats hopes of
passing a sweeping federal elections
overhaul
to combat a wave of new voting
restrictions in republican-led states
again
wave of new voting restrictions includes
things like we're not going to extend
our early voting period for a month
because it's voting day not voting month
you should have voter id which is a
widely popular measure across the united
states we're not going to allow ballot
harvesting which basically puts it in
the hands
of party activists to go door to door
and pick up ballots from people which
creates not only the incentive for voter
fraud but also for packing the ballot
box
the far-reaching bill was co-sponsored
by every democratic senator except for
senator joe manchin who called it two
partisan and introduced his own
compromise bill which was promptly
rejected by republicans
manchin ultimately voted yes to move
forward and allow debate on the bill
even though he opposes the original
legislation
by the way so this was hr1
s1 is likely to go down to the same
defeat rather hr one is
far more far-reaching than s1 so s1 is
the the mansion compromise bill
this is the sort of predicate to to that
bill hr one is uh is
wild hr one federalizes ballot
harvesting it requires public funding
for campaigns so your taxpayer money
would now go to candidates that you
don't support
it's it's a crappy piece of legislation
and mitch mcconnell
explained why exactly he was opposing it
later today the senate will vote on
whether to advance
democrats transparently partisan plan to
tilt every election in america
permanently
in their favor by now the rotten
inner workings of this power grab have
been thoroughly exposed
to the light we know that it would
shatter a decades-old
understanding that campaign finance law
should have a bipartisan referee
and turn the federal election commission
into a partisan majority cudgel for
democrats to wield
against their political opponents i mean
the number of bad provisions in this
bill
it's insane right the the what he's
talking about is the fec the fec
normally has a three republican three
democrat
bipartisan board okay the democrats
wanted to remove one of the seats they
could have a majority on the fcc and
then presumably
beat the crap out of republicans with it
it's just a bad piece of legislation
naturally democrats are portraying
the failure to advance this bill as some
sort of defeat for democracy and also a
giant victory for you guessed it
racism alrighty so the
media response to the defeat of the four
of the people act is of course
predictably overrun insane so joe biden
put out a statement notice he didn't
actually come out and say anything but
he will
he just calls everything jim crow no
that's a lie okay just let's put it
where it belongs
in the lie category now very often
people say things and it's out of
ignorance
joe biden is not ignorant that defeating
the for the people
act is not jim crow everyone knows it's
not jim crow because you know jim crow
was
an actual specific regiment of law by
which black people were discriminated
against
in law in the south by the state is
there anything remotely like that
in defeating the for the people act all
of that crap has been illegal
since the mid 60s it is now and i
checked my calendar today just to make
sure
2021 we are three generations removed
from a time when it was legal in the
united states to discriminate in law
okay fully 60 years since this has
happened or almost 60 years 57 years
since the civil rights act
and the notion here is that this is a
restoration
of what was going on in 1962 in alabama
to defeat the fourth people this isn't
even we are repealing a bunch of laws
that protect black people this is
we are failing to pass a law that
completely transforms the nature of how
voting is done in the united states and
sucks it up to the federal level
so joe biden put out this statement he
said in supporting the for the people
act and defending the rights of voters
democrats stood united for democracy
they stood against the ongoing assault
of voter suppression that represented a
jim crow era in the 21st century okay
let me put it this way
for you in the media when you say that
donald trump
lied when he said that the election was
stolen fine when you say
that voter suppression is an ongoing
threat in the united states you are
lying it is untrue
there is no evidence of widespread voter
suppression in the united states
period end of story you cannot
demonstrate any evidence of systematic
voter suppression in the united states
at all the notion that showing a voter
id is voter suppression is nonsense the
notion that if you get rid of drop boxes
that have never existed in american
elections before up until an actual
active pandemic
and then you get rid of those drop boxes
because you don't have a way of
supervising them properly that this
is jim crow voter suppression you're a
damned liar okay but they just keep
trotting this crap out
it's not true there is if you are
the pervasive myth that voter
suppression is an ongoing threat in the
united states is significantly more held
by americans
because of the media than the notion
that donald trump legitimately won the
election but i see that you only care
about one untruth about the election the
other untruth you just keep promulgating
over and over because it pushes your
political regime
says joe biden unfortunately a
democratic stand to protect our
democracy amid a solid republican wall
of opposition
senate republicans even oppose a debate
even considering legislation to protect
the right to vote and our democracy
well no they they said that they were
going to filibuster the bill which is
something that you guys do regularly
i'm old enough to remember last year
when you filibustered tim scott's police
reform bill it was the suppression of a
bill to end voter suppression another
attack on voting rights that is sadly
not unprecedented
the creed we shall overcome is a long
time mainstay of the civil rights
movement
says joe biden i'm sorry joe biden
singing from the hymnal of we shall
overcome is like
a little nauseating and i love that
kamala harris goes right along with it
five seconds ago she was calling him a
vicious racist who was trying to
keep her out of school little girls like
her out of desegregated schools
by coming together says joe biden
democrats took the next step forward in
this continuous
struggle and a step forward to honor all
those who came before us people of
all races and ages who sacrificed and
died to protect the sacred white
right okay so just to be straight about
this no one
sacrificed and died so that the election
procedures of the united states would be
federalized
ballot harvesting legalized and public
funding of elections
made law no one in america has
sacrificed and died for that particular
procedure
no one amazing how the conventional
wisdom shifted so fast
on the left from america's democracy
will survive and thrive under barack
obama too if we don't pass this bill
right now american democracy's dead and
we're finished
amazing but says joe biden the fight is
far from over nope it's over here is
vp harris declaring that the fight is
not over spoiler alert it's over
this is about the american people's
right to vote
unfettered it is about their access to
the right to vote in a meaningful way
because nobody is debating i don't
believe whether all americans have the
right to vote
the issue here is is there actual access
to the voting process or is that being
impeded
and uh the bottom line is that the
president and i are very clear
we support s1 we support the john lewis
voting rights act
and the fight is not over the fight is
over and
are you serious the ticket that she is
on
won 80 million votes in the last
election cycle
80 million votes and she's talking about
voter suppression
you want to talk about election lies
that undermine election credibility and
confidence
this would be it because guess what next
time democrats lose a presidential
election you know what they're going to
claim
voter suppression they were planning to
do it if trump had won last time
make no mistake democrats were openly
preparing the narrative that if trump
won last time it was because of voter
suppression remember the whole crap
about how
louis de joy over at the post office was
secretly removing and burning post boxes
remember this they were pushing this
crap months in advance of the election
then it turned out
as the polls shifted heavily in biden's
favor it went to well you know
probably the big threat is that that is
that
joe biden is go that donald trump won't
accept the outcome of the this is going
to be the cleanest election ever run
it's amazing how fast they shifted from
this election is probably going to be
dirty to this election is the cleanest
election ever run
completely dependent on the polls so the
whole goal here of course
is to not push forward good legislation
the point is to polarize the american
electorate along the lines of race
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist here
that is just science